Black Panther is a hugely important marvel
character.
Hugely important in the history of comics,
and it felt like the best way to introduce
him was in Captain America Civil War.
When there was an opportunity in the Civil
War development process, we needed another
character.
He was the one and only person on the list
Introducing Black Panther was really, really
exciting for us and sort of fortified our
belief that he deserved his own standalone
movie.
We put together a cast and a crew among the
best we've ever assembled.
Led by director Ryan Coogler.
Panther, kind of exists in a grey area.
In addition to being a soldier, he also has
a more important job, which is a politician.
He's constantly making these choices in the
fog of politics, the fog of war.
We deal with royalty, we deal with royal families.
But unlike our other films, it's right here
on earth, we get to explore different cultures.
And different aspects of our world.
For Black Panther and the world of Wakanda,
it's finding those real life touchstones that
we think gives the film an integrity, yet
still making it something that you've never
seen before.
Hey Youtubers, it's Charlie let's break down
some of this Black Panther.
This will be one of the first of many Black
Panther avengers videos that will be coming
this year be sure to subscribe to get everything
I'll be doing giveaways for all of them.
All you have to do to enter is be a subscriber
leave a comment on this video about Black
Panther stuff is for a copy of the Doctor
strange DVD I always announce winners at the
end of videos like they say Black Panther
isn't going to look like anything you've seen
before in the marvel universe we've been to
Eastern Europe but we've never been to this
part of Africa with the exception of the brief
visit during Avengers Age of Ultron with the
tie into Ulysses Klaw who's actually been
spotted on set recently it's going to be so
fun to see Andy Serkis come back now.
A lot of the movie's being filmed in South
Korea, but obviously Black Panther is going
to be in infinity war.
So there's a lot of stuff happening in Atlanta
were Marvel films most of its movies most
of the Wakanda stuff there filming in South
Korea that's just because of film credits
and a lot of people were wondering why they
don't actually film in Africa sometimes it's
just cheaper for them to film in different
places in the world.
That's the only reason, but they're sort of
teasing that a big part of the movie is just
going to be him kicking ass and I'll talk
about that in the second but it's also him
working as a politician because he is King
of Wakanda now.
So he's kind of like the midpoint between
Tony Stark and Captain America Captain America
always thinks with his heart wants to do the
right thing.
Tony Stark is more of the gray area thinking
more like a politician like a business owner,
so sometimes he makes choices that are super
popular, so a lot of that is serving the Black
Panther plot where decisions that his father
made are coming back to haunt him like Ulysses
Klaw who was branded the last time he tried
to still Vibranium him some of this concept
art looks like it's from their Vibranium mines
the panther here that you see in the following
talk about the fog of war.
I like they use that metaphor with the actual
fog sort of covering up this giant statue
of a panther that's made of Vibranium him
giant by bringing in panther really all this
is just meant to give you a taste of how different,
how advanced and cultured it looks compared
to the rest of the world even compared to
the United States or Europe or any of the
other places that we been in the marvel universe,
but when they were in Johannesburg fighting
that giant hold Buster versus hold bite it
look relatively decrepit compared to what's
going on here.
So that's why they been so isolationist because
they have such a precious resource is given
them access to all these wonderful things
all this education science technology.
So they've advanced much faster than the people
around them, but when you're sitting on the
kind of a Goldmine is a culture over long
period of time.
You tend to get very paranoid that was kind
of the idea the beginning of Civil War the
entrance of Wakanda opening up its borders
when Vibranium was stolen from us and use
for a very terrible thing used by old Tron
and Sokovia to kill all those people.
They decided that that was the end of their
isolationism.
So now Black Panther actually has to deal
with the reality of that.
Not everybody in Wakonda agrees with them
marvels going to be rolling out all kinds
of educational material, just to help familiarize
people with the characters throughout the
end of the year in the next year because one
year from today the movie is going to be coming
out in their lot of people who are familiar
with the character but they don't know him
the way they know Spider-Man Captain America,
Iron Man.
The other characters that they been living
with in the movies for the last 10 years or
so so here's 10 really important things about
the character number 10 Black Panther is actually
considered the first black superhero and mainstream
comics he debuted in 1966 so even though the
movie is coming out next year.
This year is his 50th anniversary Ta Nehisi
Coates has been writing this really amazing
Black Panther run since the end of secret
wars, it's kind of his version of rebirth
adjustment to familiarize people with the
culture sort of convey some of the majesty
of the character and how cool he is.
So if you're looking to pick up Black Panther.
I would recommend starting with that run,
but there couple of the runs that I mentioned
on this list, so number nine.
Panthers rage is actually considered marvels
first real graphic novel back in 1973 starting
with jungle action number five it was sort
of a loose collection of adventures focused
on Black Panther's character before he actually
got his solo title in 1977, most of you know
number eight the Black Panther is just a title
that is passed down to the person who leads
Wakonda in the comics his father was Black
Panther.
His sister was Black Panther for a while it
was not always a father to son thing is just
something that is passed down through leadership
like you see in Civil War he's wearing his
father's ring.
That's the ring of leadership, it's more of
a political royalty thing in the movies the
mantle of Black Panther seems like it was
passed down before all this happened seven
the heart-shaped herbs that he takes it gives
him Captain America level abilities without
actually being a metahuman.
So he has superhuman strength.
Superhuman speed is extra durable because
of the Vibranium and weave suit.
So the whole point of that chase during Captain
America Civil War was to just show you what a badass he is
a bad ass he is the he's able to out run Captain
America and run down a motorcycle but on top
of that he also has a PhD in physics from
Oxford University.
So we might not be Tony Stark level smart,
but he's basically a more intelligent version
of Captain America, which I think is kind
of funny number six that enables him to take
down villains as big as Mephisto.
That's right me to go toe to toe with Captain
America.
The other avengers of similar power levels,
no problem, but he's also fought and beaten
Mephisto which is just way beyond that number
five.
He married storm back in 2006 in the comics
one of Marvel's most high profile marriages
ever store marrying Black Panther May then
the power couple of the Marvel universe.
Literal power and metaphorical power because
of the political power they will that she
was Princess of her tribe so it was like a
royal marriage they an old the marriage in
2012.
Never forget that even if something really
big gap in the comics it always gets rolled
back eventually marvels kind of doing that
with their comics right now things are returning
to status quo by the end of this year.
Number four big WTF here Wesley Snipes almost
played a version of the character in the movies
back in the 90s.
Now this was before blade happened but the
project never panned out.
So was never to be a lot of people were wondering
because they're talking about doing more blade
stuff in the marvel universe may be will see
more Wesley Snipes, but it would probably
be blade related if he did come back number
three the selection make you love Chadwick
Boseman all the more so he's this really amazing
playwright stage director considered giving
up acting until he was cast in the Jackie
Robinson movie did amazing, it was an amazing
portrayal sort of reigniting his passion and
that's what got him the role of Black Panther
the Marvel people watching his performance
in that movie to behind the scenes Civil War
stuff.
He was originally a much bigger character
before Marvel got the rights to Spider-Man
Kevin fight he always says they have multiple
plans depending on what things work out what
contractual arrangements happen behind-the-scenes.
So Black Panther was always a very important
part of Civil War, but you have to imagine
that maybe 10 or 15 minutes of footage that
didn't make it into the film because they
got.
Spider-Man would just been more back story
for his character, but because they're doing
the solo film will just see all that when
we get to next February in number one he wielded
the infinity gauntlet like a bad ass during
secret wars one of the best reveals from the
end of that story, there's actually a gauntlet
assembled from infinity gems are all different
realities the Doctor strange is left behind
after he's died the Black Panther wheels while
he's waiting for Reed Richards to help take
down Doctor doom who is wielding the power
of the beyond her's.
So we just one of the people in the movies
that has potential to wield infinity gems
wield the infinity gauntlet at some point.
Even though this first infinity war film will
just be Thanos assembling the gauntlet in
a raising half of all life in the galaxy,
or at least trying to, so let me know in the
comments what you guys most hype about for
Black Panther were going to be getting a whole
lot of Black Panther later this year.
Remember what Fox did when Deadpool was coming
out all the hard-core fans really understood
the character were totally down for the movie.
But they wanted to get wider audiences to
go and get jazzed up about it.
So the going to do the same thing for Black
Panther just try to educate all the people
that don't read comics or whatever they drop
it won't be quite as ridiculous as the Deadpool
stuff obviously very different type of character,
but is going to be a lot of fun to take a
deep dive into the character through the rest
of the year.
So what can happen next is is there's new
Spider-Man homecoming, there's new Star Wars
episode eight.
So I'll try to post those videos as fast as
possible Star Wars Fridays come in tomorrow
is can be awesome.
Congratulations to Tobias you're the latest
Doctor strange DVD giveaway winner.
Please private message me on the back and
my channel so I can get your contact details.
There was a new round that started in this
video I'll just announce the winner the next
time I post a Marvel video.
Thank you so much for watching I'll see you
guys in the next video you can click here
to watch the Thor teaser again and you can
click here for that Doctor strange Post credit
scene!